so this one they they just ran over
they push
your
onto your body so you can't you can't
get it off
a lot of people
i don't know if i can do it or not so
i'm telling you the truth here
what i'm going to do because i'm going
to try and do it wrong
this arm where is if i took my knee away
it would fall down there because i'm
going to make a space with my knee what
a lot of people try and do is they take
an airway
and they move the
the hand
like the hand sticks to it and they go
like that if you do that
the other hand is pinned to the other
knee so i can't get it over to do
anything else
the intent a little bit easier the
intention is as i take the knee away
to come on top of that wrist drop it
down
roll it
like i'm rolling a rolling pin
so this is a lot this is why again i
like psytosensei because his logic works
if i do that what am i doing i'm taking
it further away
from my hands to get it
so logic tells you why would you do that
you actually need it to be closer rather
than further away
so this is another don't go backwards to
go forwards because if you're going to
go all that way to there you might not
make it
so you're all going to not all of you
but most of you're going to do it wrong
because that's
how we are
we don't quite get the timeline you've
got to take the foot away
that leg away
turn that hand down there
and instead of doing that
you see are we getting we got getting
the message now about this
all right
so it should if it doesn't
you know they're machines when you go
abroad and use you to go a fresh orange
juice they put on the machine it either
squashes it or there's a fancy one that
just takes the peel off
it's only so you can look at it it's
fancy you know it goes
it takes the peel off i'm taking the
orange peel off the
so this doesn't really much need to be
in there
and a very dear friend of mine and uh
sensei that's not here anymore tim
this was his
about 100
favorite technique
so
it turns
goes down
or else you're going to hurt your own
hand this one at the same time would
have been on top of that and there's a
small gap here and that last part
rolls him down
so this is that piece of cake that you
you all had out of the cake
all right this is the things you need so
it's
so you don't really need this but if you
do
you roll them away you don't push them
away you roll them away
okay i think you've got it
don't